okay good morning my name is Benjamin
Abraham I'm a staff anesthesiologist at
the cleveland clinic foundation in
cleveland ohio what i want to talk to
you guys today was about pain & pain
management specifically how this relates
to lab medicine family medicine primary
care and a varied number of fields so
firstly I want to let you know that I
have no financial disclosures to to
report what I intend to do here for the
talk is first to define pain we also
need to identify who is affected by pain
it's a surprising number of patients
second I wanted to talk about what the
treatments are what the treatments were
and specifically what challenges relate
to lab medicine and pain management one
of the things I mentioned was the
collaboration seems to be more and more
important as we move forward I wanted to
also mention that if there are any
questions throughout the talk please
feel free to enter those in I can
address those at the end of the talk but
I'll have a running tally of those in
the meantime so firstly what is pain the
word itself is derived from the Greek of
meaning penalty or punishment now this
tells you something in and of itself
this tells you that how pain was thought
of in the past is very different from
how its taught of today
we know this by looking at older artwork
a great example is Michelangelo's The
Last Judgment you can see here that in
this painting it's actually the devil or
Devils who are inflicting pain on on you
know on people depicted here in this
picture of various kinds there's some
thinking that in the bottom right this
is gout as evidenced by the by the demon
twisting the big toe on the person in
the corner so today we define pain as an
unpleasant sensory and emotional
experience associated with actual or
potential tissue damage or described in
terms of such damage now this is
universally the accepted definition of
pain that pain management specialists
are using a few things to note here it
the definition begins with sensory and
emotional experience associated with
this pain whereas we used to think of it
as simply biological damage causing
neuronal firing that's not so much the
case anymore so when we talk about pain
the first thing we need to know is
whether is whether it's acute or chronic
pain it could be surgical or
non-surgical pain could be malignant
pain or benign ping hey management
doctors and those that refer to pain
management doctors will need to identify
is their underlying disease has that
underlying disease been treated we also
are interested whether it's continuous
episodic is it localized is it all over
the body for those of those of you in
the audience who are clinicians we know
that there are a large number of
patients who complained of pain
everywhere this is what a lot of primary
care physicians refer to as the doorknob
question as soon as the visit is over
about their
blood pressure often patients will
report the by the way I'm having pain
all over can we talk about that so here
you have a descriptors drawn by patients
these diagrams are in some cases
pathognomonic for the conditions that
they are associated with on the left you
have a patient who we see quite a bit of
a disease called fibromyalgia on the on
the right side of your screen you have a
patient with a neuropathic pain process
and again how these patients are
describing their pay and how they're
drawing it really has an impact on how
its managed what laboratory testing is
involved and what their treatment it
will be ultimately there's a big
influence on how they're perceiving
their pain how they're drawing their
pain and ultimately what their outcome
is going to be so there's some
disagreement about what is chronic pain
chronic non-cancer pain in some some
circles is defined as persisting six
months or greater after an injury some
physicians will talk about chronic pain
being after three months we know that
chronic pain is persisting beyond the
usual course of active disease so for
example a rib fracture after the rib
heels and the patient continues to have
pain we we would consider that to be
chronic pain after three to six months
often we notice that the pain is
associated with pathological processes
not exactly not only limited to the
biological damage that may have been
done it lasts for months or years in
many cases fibromyalgia is a great
example we may not even be able to
demonstrate the pathology via lab tests
imaging
there are some cases where routine pain
control methods such as physical therapy
activity modification anti-inflammatory
medicines have no effect and the
surprise to many patients is that
healing may never occur from whatever
this process may be these definitions
were developed by the american society
of interventional pain physicians and
like many other fields such as neurology
pathology you know there are many
different opinions about the contents of
this slide one thing that's pain
physicians do agree on is that chronic
persistent pain has affects not just on
on the biology of the patient not just
on the neurons not just on the bones or
muscles we know that there's significant
impairment of physical psychological
health along with biological changes
that may have occurred we also know that
there's impairment of social
responsibilities patients may leave work
patients may have any marital problems
divorce as a result of their pain
problem so one of the things that we've
come to realize is that recognizing all
these factors he's social the
psychological as well as the biological
are combining to be necessary in order
for us to effectively treat these
chronic pain patients it's now
recognized that what we call
multidisciplinary pain care this is the
new standard whether you're an
interventional list whether you you do
pain management with a background in
psychiatry where your background is in
neurology neurosurgery this remains
something that most if not all
physicians agree on so William Osler
made a great point in order to treat
something we must first learn to
recognize it
something that's germane to this topic
is there's no lab test for pain there is
some research going on now that discount
looks at fMRI but there is no simple
established definitive test for pain
whereas there might be for cancer there
might be for hypothyroid the question is
how many pain patients are floating
around in the ether here who also are
having psychosocial dysfunction many
times a large number of these patients
either don't discuss it with their with
their physician or aren't receiving
standard of care treatments for readily
identifiable problems so the first
question is how common are these
conditions when we compare them to
diabetes cancer heart disease the
answers might surprise you when we look
at institute of medicine report done in
2011 we see that chronic pain actually
affects 116 million americans whereas
cancer the totals are 11 11 or 12
million this is not this is a trend that
has continued and in fact chronic pain
as a percentage of the population is
actually increasing at a dramatically
dramatic rate so 116 million Americans
let's look at what exactly that number
means let's look at the population of
India and the u.s. there's a big
difference there let's look at the
population of the u.s. compared to those
who are maybe in chronic pain we see
that the number of Americans who are
affected by chronic pain is actually
close to the population of Mexico
somewhere between the population of
Mexico and Japan this is startling so
within the United States we have
essentially a whole other country of
patients
within our borders who are chronic pain
patients so why would this matter to
those who are in the lab why would this
matter to primary care physicians in the
clinic why would this matter to chronic
pain physicians anesthesiologist such as
myself this is turning out to be one of
the largest public health issues in
America I'm sure that you've seen in the
news that application for disability
they are increasing at an astronomical
rate we know that this is costing us
somewhere in the neighborhood of 500 to
600 billion out of your own pocket about
two thousand dollars is coming every
year so these all these facts are
interesting because we do know based on
radiological studies those done by
Jensen those done by rathmell we know
that at over time as patients age the
amount of back pain that they actually
have decreases if you look here at the
diagram you'll see that there's a peek
at around age 40 or so and it steadily
declines thereafter we notice that
despite the radiological changes that
may increase for example the older
patient in their 80s or 90s may tell you
that they are having claudication
symptoms difficulty walking but often
they'll say that they don't really have
much back pain so this is one of the
challenges of treatment why has pain
increased more specifically back pain as
increased dramatically in the last few
years along with that our challenge is
to treat these patients so
some of the challenges that we face as
clinicians these patients seem to have
in a higher-than-expected non-compliance
rate this non compliance rate is
manifested in no-show visits it's
manifested in non concordant ear and
drug testing it's also manifested in
compliance with medication treatments
here's an example from my own my own
clinic actually this is a patient who no
showed eight times in three months now
these are visits that after each no-show
the patient made the appointment again
so they actually had to call in to the
scheduling office make another
appointment this proceeded eight times
in three months now this would give you
some idea that there are a lot of other
psychosocial issues going on here
something pertinent to this topic today
is that these patients have a large
percentage of them larger than expected
are using illicit drugs we actually
found that around fifteen percent of
chronic pain patients when we are to
check their urine or hair or blood we
find illicit drugs in about fifteen
percent of patients were prescribed who
are not prescribe controlled substances
an effect that where it is unclear as to
why we actually find that thirty thirty
four percent of these patients who are
prescribed controlled substances are
found to have illicit drugs in their
urine an area of great debate is what
effect does random drug testing
prescription monitoring pill counting
so-called adherence monitoring what
effect does this actually have on
outcome this is an area of great debate
now we've actually found a decrease in
illicit and controlled substance abuse
but it has had no effect on patient
compliance
when we look at the data when we pull
these patients anonymous that we find
that most often these patients are quote
unquote borrowing medicine from family
members the second most common is
purchasing these medicines from family
members or friends and this data is
readily available on the CDC website
it's startling to say the least one of
the things that has popped up in the
Internet age is online marketplaces many
of you have gotten the spam emails for
by a viagra now without a prescription
buy vicodin now without a prescription
and surprisingly these links actually
work hopefully none of you have clicked
on the but what we've learned from drug
rehabilitation patients is that these
medicines are readily available if you
reply to these spam emails they're
available for inflated prices but you
don't really need a prescription
something interesting that was recently
discovered was a website called the Silk
Road this website has exchanged hands
multiple times since the arrest of its
founder and those of you who are movie
buffs might recognize the name the Dread
Pirate Roberts the administrator of this
website this illegal online drug market
place actually passes the torch to the
next person without ever revealing their
identity when we look at who is
prescribing these medicines in the legal
setting we see that there are many
contributors but primary care physicians
the gatekeepers of the patients are
seemed to be the largest contributor and
they represent the highest number of
prescriptions per year
when we talk about addiction we were
finding that based on CDC data we're
having two percent of patients are self
reporting abuse of prescription drugs in
the last month CDC data also in some
studies is finding that between three
and sixteen percent of the use the u.s.
population and we're talking about
illicit drugs prescription drugs are
affected by by addiction so the question
is to understand how we're doing things
now how is pain treated in the past
going all the way back to 300 BC we know
we have descriptions of we have
descriptions of the medicinal effects of
the poppy extract morphine was isolated
purified in the 1800's injected later on
in 1850s so some some terminology that's
important this discussion is let's first
talk about opioids natural or synthetic
compounds that bind to the opioid
receptor simply put opioid analgesics
differ from opioids in that they're
opioid receptor agonist that relieve
pain there are many anti-diarrheal
agents that are opioid agonists and yet
have no pain relieving effects these are
separate from local anesthetics these
are separate from anti-inflammatory
medicines both of which may relieve pain
but aren't considered opioid analgesics
one important thing to note is that
narcotics is not a term that is usually
used in the medical parlance so how is
pain treated now pains treated now as I
mentioned through a combination of
psychological treatments and biological
treatments and social treatments in some
cases i myself was trained as an
anesthesiologist a general
anesthesiologist went on to complete
fellowship training and interventional
pain management which includes neural
Revelations spinal cord stimulation
procedures essentially to supplement our
arsenal of medications that may treat
pain when we talk about
non-interventional treatments we're
referring to anti-inflammatory medicines
physical therapy activity modification
when we talk about cognitive behavioral
therapy and psychological treatments
often the assistance of a psychologist
or a psychiatrist is required to address
comorbid depression often there is a
psychological dysfunction when we bring
the families in to enhance
accountability for these patients we
actually find outcomes are improved so
what does the research shown us thus far
we know that despite hundreds and
hundreds of years of using opioids we
know that only some patients are
achieving functional restoration with
opioid therapy there are many who do not
why is is poorly understood at this
point however there are unavoidable side
effects that we know to be the case with
these medications especially when their
daily medications especially when
they're used long-term we know that
there are changes in hormones pulmonary
mechanics sleep architecture our
colleagues in Neurology discovered the
vast number of effects on sleep
architecture using EEG recording we also
know from lab testing and research
studies that pain processing is changed
perception has changed phenomenon that
was recently discovered is something
called opioid-induced hyperalgesia
simply put this is more pain with
chronic treatment using these
medications so one of the guidelines
that many many physicians are using and
some some would say it's a common sense
guideline these medications such as
opioids are being used now as if they
were a medicine like warfarin a blood
thinner physicians are asking themselves
would I do this would I prescribe this
medicine if his patient were on warfarin
for example would I prescribe
hydrocodone if the patient was already
on oxycodone would I perform a surgery
without a discharge plan for the
patient's warfarin or in our case here a
discharge plan for the patient's oral
opioid therapy we know that surgery and
postoperative pain is increased when the
patient comes in on chronic opioid
therapy analogous to warfarin were often
needing to check the PT and the INR the
same goes for these medicines such as
hydrocodone oxycodone etc we need to
monitor them we need to monitor whether
they're actually in the patient system
or their other substance does that may
be interfering often clinicians are
asking themselves would I would I begin
another therapy such as hydrocodone and
just assume that another physician would
be taking that over often and this is
overlooked analogous to warfarin many
clinicians are asking themselves would I
add an antiplatelet agent if the patient
was already on warfarin would would you
add a second opioid if the patient is
already being prescribed a no
this is taken directly from the DEA
website whoo-hoo issues are licenses to
prescribe we know that we're expected to
follow the guidelines that they set
forth though main many clinicians aren't
aware of what those actual guidelines
are essentially you're responsible for
all federal and state regulations
regarding these controlled substances
whether you know it or not you're
responsible for patient evaluation many
of the cases you see in the newspaper of
physicians being arrested are due to
lack of evaluation secondly they may be
due to lack of evaluation physical
because I am taking trialing of
conservative therapies this is an
important aspect of these the treatment
of these patients is that trialing
non-opioid therapies patients also need
to be screened for substance abuse and
this is where laboratory testing is
essential most patients will not be
forthcoming with their substance abuse
if you're also the person writing their
controlled substances in Ohio and
throughout the United States we have a
prescription monitoring system the Ohio
automated rx reporting system this is
mirrored in many states though it's not
Universal many states do not have it in
the US
one of the critical aspects of treatment
of pain patients is identification of
what the treatment objectives actually
are some patients may expect one hundred
percent pain relief some patients would
be happy with ten percent pain relief
but not having a goal in mind really
sets sets you back one of the things
that many facilities are doing now is
informed consent making sure that these
patients are aware of what is one of the
risks for opioid therapy as the rate of
accidental overdose Rises patients seem
to be just as ill informed as they were
in the past despite the newspaper
headlines so as I mentioned patients are
having changes in pain processing
patients are having changes in pain
perception patients on chronic opioids
oftentimes will have changes in their
cold pressor test their ability to
tolerate an ice water bath on their arm
for example and this can be tested in
the lab and is readily able to be
demonstrated so what's changed why why
are we doing things differently now
often it's it's not as is the case it's
not a change in the science necessarily
it's a change in the medical licensure
so you may have heard that now there's a
a backswing whereas over prescribing was
the case perhaps ten years ago now it's
it may be under prescribing again quote
unquote now at this point over
prescribing of controlled substances the
leading cause of Investigation and
discipline for state medical boards so
whether you're a primary care physician
the writers of the most or prescriptions
in the United States or a pain physician
or a neurologist or psychiatrist
these are relevant issues if you're
seeing patients in the clinic one thing
that is important to note is that state
medical boards often aren't populated
with with experts in laboratory medicine
they aren't often populated with experts
in pain management or addiction ology
often physicians are disciplined in
states around the country despite expert
testimony so this graph is very telling
you'll notice the trend at the top
there's a neat pretty much a steady
increase in 2006 for example used to use
Ohio as an example there was 183
disciplinary actions whereas in 2011
numbers 217 now you might say well what
happened in 2011 there was a bill called
house bill 93 which greatly changed the
regulations surrounding prescription of
opioid medications if you look down at
the bottom you'll see that prescribing
issues actually jumped from 30 from six
to thirty eight as the reason for
disciplinary action so the question then
is what are the state medical boards
using to guide their their decisions one
study looked at the state medical boards
and actually pulled medical board
members in various states in the US
asked about first day first day their
demographics what their knowledge was of
the actual federal and state laws and
what were their clinical beliefs so
strangely
so 37-percent rated their own training
and pain management as excellent or good
along similar lines 22% rated their
training and addiction ology as
excellent or good however only
twenty-five percent a quarter of the
board members whose remember who's a
training was excellent or good as they
rated it only twenty-five percent could
correctly define addiction thirteen
percent thought they knew what the
accepted current definitions of
addiction were but were incorrect so
while addiction iatrogenic addiction to
opioids is fairly low when it's used to
treat chronic non-malignant pain
non-cancer pain forty-six percent of
state medical board members actually
believe it to be a common occurrence in
fact ninety-one percent believe
diversion and abuse were a problem in
their state whether this is related to
politics or not is is unclear so these
results should surprise surprise you so
what do we know about dependence we know
that dependence is a maladaptive pattern
of substance use leading to impairment
or distress it actually requires
tolerance withdrawal taking larger
amounts than is intended also requires
the desire or unsuccessful attempts to
cut down and this is from dsm for
substance abuse again is a malbec
adaptive pattern of substance use
leading to impairment or distress
requires within the year recurrent
issues
fulfilling major role obligation so work
school situations where it's physically
hazardous legal problems to summarize a
patient has an addiction with compulsive
use despite harm this is the sort of one
sentence summary here it's important to
note that the dsm-4 doesn't talk about
addiction this is not a defined
diagnosis in the DSM for nor is it in
dsm-5 so while a notable proportion of
state medical boards don't recognize the
legal acceptability of chronic opioid
therapy state like state guidelines in
place in these very same states support
and encourage the use of chronic opioid
therapy for non-cancer pain in fact you
may have noticed court cases where the
under treatment of pain was actually
found to be malpractice so while eighty
percent of board members believe that
the state policies for opioids and
opioid regulation was useful only
forty-three percent actually knew the
laws so for example twenty-seven percent
thought that physicians who aren't
addiction ologist could write for
methadone for chronic non-malignant pain
the fact is is that anyone with a DEA
license to prescribe scheduled
medications can write for methadone if
it's for the treatment of pain and not
for opioid addiction or detox also only
about half of the board members knew
that there was no limit on the quantity
of opioids prescribed at one time
so more than a quarter would doubt the
legitimacy of a physician writing for
more than 100 period at a time we know
that often patients are prescribed
long-acting and short-acting medicines
at the same time the evidence for this
is not settled by any means whether this
is medically justified or not we don't
know but we do know that it drastically
reduces the risk for accidental
addiction so we do know that board
members who discover or who defined
addiction incorrectly were also the same
physicians who were likely to review
chronic opioid therapy for non-cancer
pain as unlawful or unacceptable what we
do know is that the opioid prescriptions
despite evidence of harm are increasing
in their use for chronic non-cancer pain
we know that opioids aren't effective in
many cases we do know that there's a lot
of uncertainty regarding the long-term
benefits this is largely due to the fact
that many of these control trials if
indeed they are randomized control
trials many of them have a very large
dropout rate
so one such meta-analysis looked at 70
randomized control trials looking at the
benefits versus harm of chronic opioid
therapy and non-malignant pain and
indeed most of the trials were less than
16 weeks long unfortunately and this is
often the case with developing a
randomized controlled trial is you have
to exclude the high-risk patients you
have to exclude patients with
psychiatric comorbidities whereas often
these are the large percentage of
patients who are in the clinic's whether
its internal medicine neurology headache
clinics we do know that there's little
to no evidence for chronic opioid
therapy and low back pain and yet in
many clinics this is the most common use
of these medications as you can see
there's quite a quite a research gap
here we know that a lot of these
guidelines as a result were developed by
expert consensus they weren't
necessarily randomized control trials as
would be the standard for many other
treatments in many other fields so 37
critical research questions were
identified by the American Pain Society
in American Academy of pain medicine
that should suggest you that there's a
large need for ongoing research one of
the attempts to classify who should be
receiving opioids examines the diagnosis
the intractability of the patient the
row of the pain the reliability of the
patient and the efficacy the effect of
these medicines on patient function
despite research into this area despite
these guidelines the evidence for
chronic opioid therapy remains scant we
know that we have far greater much more
solid evidence for non-opioid
interventions to treat chronic
non-cancer pain so let's talk about drug
testing when we looked at internal
medicine we we know that internal
medicine residents often a reporting
high confidence and yet low knowledge
scores when actually examining the
interpretation of urine drug tests so
when we looked at objective measures of
urine drug testing we found that 99
residents for example scored a three out
of seven on this test it's a seven
question test regarding their objective
knowledge of lab testing in regards to
compliance for these patients we did
notice that there's a significant
difference in male versus female
residents we did know that their
confidence score as their confidence in
their knowledge increased their score is
actually decreased on objective testing
so what do we know we know that chronic
pain is now the number one most common
condition in the United States as far as
medical diseases go if we can call it a
single medical disease it remains one of
the most challenging to treat since 2008
and indeed before that it's the most
common source of disability in modern
society so effective treatment of this
population is going to require
marshaling resources from laboratory
medicine to help educate physicians such
as myself in pain management internal
medicine neurology and
in psychiatry psychology in order to
monitor compliance in order to prevent
accidental overdose and maximize benefit
Ethan deed controlled substances are
used in these patients treatments so I
could be happy to answer some questions
if there were any well I'd like to thank
everyone for participating and enjoy the
rest of your day